(audience cheering)
- [Narrator] The class of 2022 is heading
into a great job market.
- Let me add my congratulations
to all of you for this
extraordinary accomplishment
under challenging,
unprecedented circumstances.
- They are the most
in-demand college graduates
to enter the job market in years.
- It took a long time to get any responses
and then very suddenly,
I started getting many interview requests.
- This job market is
the tightest for labor
that I have seen.
- [Narrator] The nationwide
labor shortage means grads
are in high demand, and they know it.
- I think happiness and
the ability to be happy
at your workspace has been
more prioritized now than ever.
Wanting a job that's going
to not only be something
that pays well, and is
fulfilling professionally,
but also fulfilling emotionally.
- [Narrator] So as the class
of 2022 enters the workforce
with far more leverage than
grads from recent years,
how should they approach the job market?
- I casted a wide net.
I was looking for jobs everywhere.
New England, the
Southeast, the West Coast.
- [Narrator] Top of line
for many grads is salary.
- The pay was the most
important thing for me.
I have expenses,
I know I will have college
loan payments coming soon.
And making sure that I
am prepared for those
is the most important thing.
- [Narrator] A shortage
of entry-level workers
in some sectors have
led to starting salaries
of $100,000 or more for
inexperienced workers.
- They are very aware of the tumult
of the last few years
and are really looking for stability
and the dollar figure on that paycheck
is going a long way for many individuals.
- [Narrator] Flexibility is also important
to these recent grads.
Because new graduates
can afford to be choosy,
some are taking their
time to lock in a new job.
According to a recent survey,
about half of new grads who hadn't decided
on a job had gotten at least
one offer without accepting.
- There are students that I can think of
who have had offers in hand
that they are just about to accept
and then are contacted by recruiters
from other organizations
to say we urgently
have an opportunity we
want you to consider.
- [Narrator] That's what
happened to Austin Bowles
who recently accepted a
position as a staff electrician
at Northern Stage, a theater in Vermont.
- To be totally honest here,
Northern Stage actually wasn't
the first place I accepted.
I accepted another job,
a summer stock job is what we call it.
It's a temporary only for the summer.
I had accepted that in South Carolina
and it wasn't until some time in March
when I got an email from Northern Stage
saying we'd like to interview.
And so I actually had to give
them an unfortunate call,
letting them know that I wouldn't go there
and I was gonna go here.
So I do wish I had gone a little slower.
- [Narrator] Outside of salary,
many recent grads have other requests
for their future employers.
- I'm a first generation
low-income college student
and I very much, yes, salary was something
that was very important
but on top of that,
I also wanted a company
that was gonna prioritize
my work-life balance,
and I also wanted to be able to do work
that I felt very proud of
but also was very interested in.
- [Narrator] Eugene Thomas
recently graduated from Yale.
After interning at John
Deere over the summer,
he took a position with
the company in Iowa.
- Students are very
discerning and thoughtful
about how the organization's
values line up
with their values.
And that is certainly
around issues of diversity,
equity and inclusion.
- And I felt really comfortable
with the entire team
of engineers at John Deere.
I was able to visit
Waterloo, Iowa at some point
throughout the summer.
Every single one of the members
of the engineering team made
me feel very comfortable.
- [Narrator] One of the biggest challenges
for recent grads is housing,
which has been made more difficult
by the recent surge in rental prices.
- The place I'm currently
working with here
at Northern Stage, they
have subsidized housing
and that was a key factor in the decision.
- I am from New York City
and I guess there was some inventive
to work in a place where cost of living
is considerably lower than New York City
and even New Haven, Connecticut.
- [Narrator] Median apartment rents
are up more than 60% in the past year
and up 28% since January of 2017.
- They saw their families impacted
by the Great Recession years ago.
They certainly have
seen people be impacted
by the pandemic and
corresponding implement crisis
that resulted from that,
and the tight finances that
people felt during those times.
And to some degree are still feeling.
So I think the rental prices
and the concern about where will I live
and how will I finance this
are connected to the salary conversations
that folks are having.
- [Narrator] After years
of working remotely,
Grubb said many students
wanna get into the field.
- I have talked personally
with a few students
who worked for organizations
as a summer intern,
and those internships were fully virtual.
And while these students are very grateful
to have those experiences,
they feel like they missed
out on opportunities
to connect with other
people in their workplaces.
- Hands-on experience
was very important to me,
especially I think the class
of '22 is really special
in that respect,
especially in industries like engineering
because a lot of your classes
during your junior year
would have been done more
hands-on and in person
and that entire year was
remote, at least for Yale.
On top of that, my summer internship,
with the exception of one week was remote,
and I was able to have a lot
of great experience there
and a lot of exposure,
however, I would have
loved if it were in person,
COVID permitting to have
more hands-on experience,
and I'm really excited to get some
throughout my post-grad job.
(dramatic music)